i want to do a little bit of a follow-up
about the will smith slap of chris rock
during the oscars on sunday night um the
american right wing
seems to have lost its mind and are
delivering
bizarre
take after take
about what happened or what didn't
actually happen on sunday night now i'm
going to talk a little bit
uh in a little bit
about kind of what my my now having had
a chance to think about it more
what my view is on what happened on
sunday night for those of you who don't
know chris rock during the oscars made a
joke about will smith's wife's short
hair which is um
the style she chooses because she has
alopecia of baldness
and will smith didn't like it and he
walked up to chris rock during the
oscars and slapped him in the face
and then yelled keep my wife's name out
of your mouth it was an insane situation
and i'm going to talk about my thoughts
in a moment but first let me show you
some just bizarre takes
cultural critic and arbiter of ideas
dave rubin um
said that
if it had been a white person who did
the slap
then everybody would have gone crazy and
he's mad about that so he's upset about
how people would have reacted in a
different situation
what are you even talking about dude um
but but because they know no one's
paying attention would you put it above
the machinery of hollywood what to
fabricate something like this that that
chris rock makes a fairly innocuous joke
i mean she's got a shaven head and i'll
talk more about alopecia in a sec as i
said um and that will smith so loses
control he's laughing at the joke at
first that he so lost control of himself
that on an evening where he knows
millions even though it's not as many
millions as it used to be millions of
people are watching that he so lost
control of himself that he walks up on
stage comment he didn't bum rush the
stage right he walks up there smacks the
guy and just sits down no security came
and got him so far he's spot on i like
this analysis so far
uh nobody you know apparently during the
commercials there were some pr people
saying something to him um but you know
we could also add like the weird woke
element of race to this so it was black
on black violence which people obviously
treat a little bit differently i suspect
that woke element what if matt damon had
gotten out of the crowd very pasty white
matt damon had gotten out of the crowd
and smacked chris rock we'd be there
would be riots in the streets okay so
now it's just completely unhinged yeah
it's it's not going to be if it was matt
damon who slapped chris rock
you were not going to see the rodney
king riots or anything like that so the
with the woke aspect of this just a
bizarre take he's mad about how people
would have reacted to something that
didn't happen how is that a story then
we go to fox news where donald trump's
former press secretary kelly mcinanny
uh compared what happened to when
michelle wolf joked about sarah huckabee
sanders and right wingers were mad and
it has nothing to do with it whatsoever
could have stopped him i would hope but
because he's will smith they just don't
yeah i think trace made the key point
you know if it was a fan it'd be totally
different treatment than it would be for
a celebrity and also i think very
different scenario when you think too i
couldn't get out of my head as i watched
this the white house correspondents
association dinner from 2018 where sarah
sanders was so maliciously attacked um
you had samantha samantha wolf or b
whatever the heck her name is michelle
wolf going after sarah sanders for her
appearance and minutes long excruciating
detail and i watched sarah sanders sit
there my predecessor with such grace and
poise and kindness and just sit there
and take it because if you're a
republican woman
you got to take it if you're a celebrity
you engage in this behavior and you'll
have people come to your defense jamal
bowman another congressman came to the
defense of will smith you had a cnn
commentator who actually blamed this on
donald trump coming to will smith's
defense but if i just may make this one
ancillary point just like i didn't like
the jokes about sarah sanders i did not
like that joke about will smith's wife i
had a friend who i grew up with who had
alopecia and i just thought it was
totally out of bed okay so
again there it it really isn't uh
whatever point she's trying to make is
not landing and it's always somehow
about wokeness and people and
criticizing and double standards with
conservatives last clip here this is
sunny hostin from the view not a right
winger per se but sort of sometimes a
contrarian on that show or maybe
compared to the others in any case she
talks about um how this is a uh this was
an instance of toxic max masculinity and
i think that when that type of thing
when you live publicly
you don't have the right to all of a
sudden decide to um execute violence and
i have to say that was a show of toxic
masculinity if he was offended and felt
emasculated by regina hall's joke uh or
by chris chris
rock's joke you don't act out in
violence that is not a show of love
that's a show of violence and i think
that um and then lastly kyle becker the
ceo of becker news a former fox news
producer tweeting if will smith was a
white guy he would have been let out of
the oscars in handcuffs then police
would have thrown him in jail there
would be a thousand media hit pieces
about him being racist he would be
canceled for life and steady one best
actor that's privilege and of course
that's also untrue uh chris rock
declined to press charges and and that's
sort of it so
i have to tell you there are little
pieces of what these people said that
actually do make a lot of sense
what we have here was
maybe an a distasteful joke by chris
rock
and then a physical attack these are not
on the same playing field it it it's
will smith is right to be completely
humiliated by what he did it's
embarrassing number one
number two
even if it indeed will smith was sort of
standing up for his wife
uh she was not in any kind of physical
danger right stay physically slapping
someone
would be legitimate to stand up for your
wife
if it's a defense to a physical attack
there was no physical danger and number
number three
it is notable that no security get
involved in any way now i know that it's
easy to say well security would never
think that will smith's gonna slap chris
rock there's no reason that they would
do that okay but it is also kind of
reflective more generally of the academy
staff did nothing to prevent this in any
way they didn't make any effort to
explain why will smith stayed in the
building after a physical attack the
physical attack is completely out of
bounds and as a big will smith fan
myself he should be completely
humiliated by what happened here at the
end of the day this whole thing about
well it would the joke was very off
color i don't disagree
the joke was off color you're sitting in
the front row at the oscars this is what
happens at the oscars there's a roast
element there's a roast aspect to this
these people make millions and millions
of dollars you can take a bad joke you
don't need to go and physically slap
someone and will smith is
unilaterally in the wrong there we'll
have these clips on our instagram at
david pakman show where you can also let
me know your thoughts about my analysis
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping